this is the calm before Westminster's
weekend storm on Saturday MPs will face
off in Parliament in a special session
they have just one day of debate to
accept or reject Boris Johnson's new
brexit deal and decide the future of
this country if they say no the Prime
Minister must ask the EU for a brexit
extension something he's desperate to
avoid I hope that people will think well
you know what's the valence one of our
constituents really want do they want us
to keep going with this argument do they
want more division and delay or do they
want us to focus on putting more money
into your NHS which is what we're doing
expanding a provision for lifting up
provision for education and and putting
more police out on the streets tackling
knife crime those against the deal are
hoping opposition parties can hold the
line we all know it's going to be tight
and the only way Boris Johnson can
deliver his bricks it is if Labour MPs
break runs in vote for a Tory brexit
with Northern Ireland's DUP ruling
themselves out there are three key
groups Boris Johnson must win over for
the needed 320 votes there are a group
of Labour MPs in mostly and leave voting
seats who want to see brexit done but
aren't sure whether or not they're going
to back this particular deal there's the
former Conservative MPs who have thrown
asked the party for opposing no deal
most of those voted for Theresa Mays
deal but might take issue with a
slightly harder brexit that's being
proposed by Boris Johnson and then
there's the 28 Tory brexit is who voted
three times against Mays deal it's a big
ask and a cross-party group of brexit
moderates still aren't convinced that no
deal is off the table
led by the former Conservative MP Oliver
let win they're trying to amend
saturday's vote so that any approval for
the prime ministers deal would be
deferred until the legislation to enact
it have been passed
so brexit would be delayed until the end
of January so that MPs could get all the
complicated work done and not crash out
on October the 31st because they'd run
out of time
but there's no guarantee that EU leaders
would say yes to an extension
Bosko I think we should stick to the
October 31st deadline
I don't indulge in political fiction so
I'm not going to imagine a scenario
where the British Parliament votes this
way or that way but I don't think that
any new extension should be agreed to
you despite what macron says it's hard
to see EU leaders denying an extension
and risk being blamed for an Odile crash
out but yet again the UK is pushing
brexit right down to the wire Rory
challon's outers era London